[موسيقى]
بامر منها تندلع الحروب وبامر اخر تنطفئ
تخشاها امريكا لانها تمسك بقبضتها الغليظه
عنق اقوى دول العالم تكره الصين وتحاول ان
تكسب روسيا هي من وضعت حجر الاساس لقيام
اسرائيل ودعمتها بشكل لا يصدقه عقل شكرها
نتنياهو علنا وصوره احد افرادها توجد على
العمله الاسرائيليه انها عائله الظل الاس
اسود لا بل نحن نتحدث عن عائله روتشيلد
اليهوديه كيف تحولت عائله روتشيلد من اسره
بسيطه الى امبراطوريه مرعبه وكيف تحكمت
اذرعها في مقدرات القاره الاوروبيه وامتدت
الى الشرق الاوسط والدول العربيه وما هو
التقرير الخبيث الذي نفذته تلك العائله
واسست بما تسمى اليوم اسرائيل لتعرف اجابه
كل تلك الاسئله تابع ال فيديو للنهايه
الداهيه ماير امشيل روتشيلد ولد عام
1744 بمدينه فرانكفورت لعائله يهوديه
المانيه تعلم من ابيه اصول تجاره المال
ونقصد هنا الاقراض بفوائد تضمن زياده
الثروه دون ان تتحرك من مكانها وبعد وفاه
ابيه ضرب ماير اروع مثال لتفوق التلميذ
على الاستاذ فجمع بين المال وال السلطه
والنفوذ وكون امبراطوريه من المال اصبحت
ذراعا سياسيا يتحكم في دول وحكومات
باكملها تندلع حروب باوامر من ماير
روتشيلد وابنائه وتنتهي باوامر ايضا اللهب
في كل مكان وشعوب تعاني من الجوع والعطش
ودول تعلن استقلالها واخرى تقع تحت وطاه
الاحتلال وكلمه السر هنا عائله روتشيلد
قواعد الز
وقضبان ناعمه حتى الزواج بالنسبه لمايل
روتشيلد كان نوعا من الاستثمار فقد تزوج
من ابنه مصرفي الماني كبير انجبت له عشره
من الابناء كان الذكور منهم هم نواه
امبراطوريه روتشيلد التي حكمت اوروبا بل
ومعظم دول العالم اشهر ابنائه ناثان وجيمس
والذان تحكما في اكبر امبراطوريتي في
العالم انذاك ونقصد هنا بريطانيا وفرنسا
وضع ماير لابنائه قواعد صارمه في الزواج
اهمها ان يتزوجوا من خارج العائله ومن
يخالف ذلك يتم حرمانه من الميراث كما ان
الذكور فقط هم من يحق لهم الميراث وذلك
حتى يضمن ماير عدم خروج الثروه الطائله
خارج العائله التحكم في العالم بعد وفاه
ماير روتشيلد عام
1812 كان خمسه من ابنائه وهم ثان وجيمس
واشيل وسلوم وكارل قد كونوا امبراطوريات
مصرفيه ضخمه في معظم دول اوروبا اشهرها
بريطانيا وفرنسا والنمسا وايطاليا
والمانيا بالطبع وتحول ذراع ماير الى اذرع
عديده تمسك بقبضتها في عنق القاره العجوز
اعتمد ابناء روتشيلد على استراتيجيه موحده
وهي اقراض الطبقات الارستقراطيه والحاكم
في البلدان التي يتواجدون فيها حتى منح
البابا فرانسيس ثاني الابناء الخمسه لقب
البارون لتدخل عائله روتشيلد الى طبقه
النبلاء من اوسع ابوابها ولمع نجم العائله
المصرفيه في فتره حرب نابوليون في اوروبا
او ما يطلق عليها باسم الحروب النابليونيه
حينها كان ابناء روتشيلد يدعمون الاطراف
المتحاربه وعندما يدعم احدهم طرفا في
الحرب يدعم اخوه الطرف الاخر ليضمنوا بذلك
تضخم ثروتهم وزياده نفوذهم فاي طرف سينتصر
في النهايه سيكون حتما من اتباع احد ابناء
تلك العائله وربما كان احد اشهر ادوار
عائله روتشيلد السياسه الكبرى هو استقلال
البرازيل عن البرتغال فعندما تم الاعت فاق
على ان تدفع البرازيل للبرتغال مبلغ
مليوني جنيه استرليني نظير استقلالها قام
ناثان روتشر باقراض البرازيل المبلغ
بفوائد مضاعفه لتتخلص البرازيل من احتلال
للبرتغال ولكنها وضعت عنقها تحت مقصله
حاده وهي قروض عائله روتشيلد حكومات تسقط
واخرى تقوم الحروب ملات القاره الاوروبيه
المنتصر فيها مهزوم وكلمه السر في كل ذلك
هي اموال ونفوذ ابناء روتشيلد ولم تكتفي
هذه العائله بالتحكم في مقدرات القاره
الاوروبيه
ومستعمراتها بل مد احفادهم خيوطه الغليظه
ليطوفوا عنق الشرق الاوسط والعرب بفتات
المدلله ونقصد هنا اسرائيل فكيف حدث هذا
وضع اللبنت الاولى ان مساهمه عائلتي في
تاسيس دوله اسرائيل كانت حاسمه عائلتنا هي
التي اسست اسرائيل بتلك الكلمات عبر احد
احفاد روتشيلد وهو جيكوب روتشيلد عن دور
عائلته في دعم وتاسيس اسرائيل في الذكرى
المئويه لوعد بلفور ورغم قوه الكلمات لم
يبت جيكوب روتشيلد عن الحقيقه فقد تبنت
عائله روتشيلد تنفيذ بنود اهم تقرير ادى
لقيام اسرائيل ونقصد هنا تقرير بانرمان
والذي اعده رئيس وزراء بريطانيا هنري
بانرمان عام
1907 اي قبل وعد بلفور بعره اعوام ويقول
التقرير ان منطقه شمال افريقيا وشرق البحر
المتوسط هي الورث المحتمل للحضاره
الاوروبيه الحديثه ولكن تلك المنط طقه
تناصب الحضاره الغربيه العداء لذا يجب
تقسيمها واثاره العداوه بين طوائفها وناتي
للبند الاكثر اهميه في التقرير وهو زرع
جسم غريب في المنطقه يفصل بين شرق البحر
المتوسط والشمال الافريقي بالطبع يا عزيزي
قد علمت الان ما هو الجسم الغريب الذي تم
زرعه في المنطقه وفقا لهذا التقرير والذي
تبنته عائله روتشيلد واخذت على عاتقها
مهمه تنفيذه بحذا ره ولكن هل انتهى دعم
ملوك المال والذهب لاسرائيل عند هذا الحد
دعم لا يصدق اقدم لك الشكر باسم حكومه
اسرائيل انت تمضي في اعقاب اسلفك الذين
كونوا تقليدا عريقا لتشكل قدوه عظيمه
لاولئك الذين يتبعونك ايضا شكرا لك بهذه
الكلمات شكر بنيامين نتنياهو جيكوب روتش
في احدى المناسبات على جهود عائلته ودعمها
الضخم الذي نتج عنه في النهايه دولتهم
القائمه الان ففي سبعينيات القرن ال ع
كانت عائله روتش تدفع نصف مليون فرنك
سنويا لصالح يهود الشرق كما ان احد افراد
العائله وهو ليونيل روتشيلد كان اليد
الضاغطه على الحكومه البريطانيه حتى اصدر
وعد بلفور الشهير كما قام ليونيل بتمويل
فيلق عسكري يهودي يحارب بجانب الجيش
البريطاني في الحرب العالميه الاولى وفي
نفس الوقت قام بتاسيس هيئه الهجره التي
تنظم هجره اليهود الى فلسطين وكان رئيس
تلك الهيئه جيمس ارماند روتشيلد الذي عمل
على جمع اليهود من مختلف دول اوروبا
وتهجيرهم الى فلسطين اما البارون ادموند
جيمس روتشر فقد كان هو المؤسس الحقيقي
لاول مستوطنه يهوديه في فلسطين فهو من دفع
ثمن بعض الاراضي لاصحابها ليتنازل عنها
لصالح اليهود ونحن هنا لا نقصد قول بان
الفلسطينيين هم من باعوا ارضهم فقد كان
الملاك الذين باعوا ارضهم لصالح اليهود هم
من غير الفلسطينيين كما ان مساحه تلك
الاراضي المباعه كانت صغيره جدا ولكن شبرا
واحدا في البدايه كان كافيا جدا التهام
الارض لم يتوقف دعم ملوك المال والذهب
لاسرائيل عند هذا الحد ايضا ففي عام
1924 قامت عائله شيلد بتاسيس الرابطه
الاستعماريه في فلسطين والتي استولت على
الكثير من الاراضي ناهيك عن الاستثمارات
الضخمه التي دعمت اقتصاد اليهودي في
المنطقه ليتوج جيمس راتشل دعم عائلته
بتمويل بناء الكنيست كهديه لاسرائيل حفظ
الجميل ربما كان دعم عائله روتشيلد
لاسرائيل اكبر بكثير مما ذكرنا الامر الذي
دفع الحكومه الاسرائيليه عام 882 لان تضع
صوره البارون ادموند جيمس دي روتشيلد على
فئه ال 500 شكل وحتى اليوم ورغم الدهم
الذي تتلقاه اسرائيل من جهه مختلفه يظل
ضعم عائله روتشيلد للدوله العبريه محفورا
في الذاكره كالنقش على الحجر اذا هنا
السؤال لكم مشاهدينا هل كنت تعلم دور
عائله روتشر في اقامه اسرائيل وهل ترى ان
تلك العائله تتحكم حتى في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بطريقه او باخرى ام انها مجرد
اراء لا تستند على ادله حقيقيه اخبرونا في
صندوق
[موسيقى]
التعليقات